[Music]
a genre evolved into a project about
becoming a king training to accept the
responsibility of the power I inherited
Random Acts program to the pirate
program
is titled the parable of the pirate and
the King
so in episode six nausea is a king I
would say generally the king's dilemma
is how to willpower responsibly given
that most of our reference points for
observing people with power are toxic as
John learns that the only way to hold
power responsibly is through rituals
that put her in touch with power that is
beyond the body in naja's case the power
that she has is spiritual power she's
being initiated into certain ways of
being that offer her spiritual power
power of connection that everybody
doesn't have a genre uses ritual to
strengthen her multi-generational
relationships with the land and in the
strength of her people just a lot going
on ancestrally with this lady you know
what I mean
being a person from a Bourgeois family
in a colonial context with the history
of subjugation history of enslavement
these are not your people these are
slave masters and also a history on her
father's side that she didn't know about
and the question being how does she
organize herself in recognition of
having and possessing all these powers
she's also in observation of what it is
like as it came to be in connection with
the pirate and what the utility of that
is what the usefulness of that
interaction could be you know why she
chose it in this lifetime that's what
she's up to in episode six in the sixth
dimension
[Music]